Welcome back, everyone, to
new this morning.
Ohio's
Education Department
is investigating
an alleged
Nazi homeschooling network
that reportedly distributed
lesson plans
with writing exercises
based on Hitler quotes.
To explain, Omar Jimenez is here.
Do tell. Good morning to you.
Good morning.
Now, for starters,
the state education official tol
the Ohio Department of Education
is basically reviewing complianc
with statutory
and regulatory policies
in this state
because it's not clear
how much they can actually do
about the curriculum of homescho
Now, I want to show you an examp
This is a group
that they believe operates
out of Upper Sandusky, Ohio.
And this is an example of a Than
copy working assignment
where basically,
you know,
you're learning handwriting,
elementary school age,
and they're using
Hitler quotes to learn that hand
You know, this is a group
that doesn't hide
being pro-Nazi,
white supremacist, homophobic,
honestly, you name it,
it's probably there.
I want to show another lesson
that was posted, quote, less
and leading up to Martin
Luther King
Jr day, this was by a user named
Saxon.
She wrote,
It is up to us to ensure our chi
know him. Dr. Martin Luther King
For the deceitful, dishonest, ri
inducing negro he actually was.
He is the face of a movement
which ethnically cleansed
whites out of urban areas
and precipitated the anti-white
that we are now
fighting to free ourselves
from an emboldened underlined un
She wrote
This is a lesson
for elementary age children.
I wonder how the local school di
is responding,
but also because it's home schoo
they do have to be certified
to be able to get the credits ri
I just wonder what they can do,
if anything, to stop Basically,
there's there's an annual check
sort of to show that you are tea
Now, what you are teaching
is sort of out of their purview
and sort of the
the upper Sandusky school
district superintendent
basically said
this is egregious, these teachin
We don't support it.
But also said as part of his sta
parents are responsible
for choosing the curriculum
in homeschooling and the course
The parents
chosen curriculum is not sponsor
or endorsed by the district.
The group's got more than 3000 r
You know,
we tried to reach out to the own
I didn't get a response.
Maybe no surprise there.
But obviously something that the
is paying close attention to.
Oh, boy.
Thank you, Grandma. Or see you